dear Elon Musk I saw your Vegas Loop  operate during CES and I was very  impressed as a fellow genius I'd like to  give you some tips to make the Vegas  Loop even better first instead of  inefficient rubber tiles and asphalt  road I propose switching to a low  friction metallic wheel system with a  double vibranium hyper guide rail second  instead of heavy and polluting batteries  what if we invented a constant adjacent  power source the vehicles can draw from  the Tony Stark Thunder jolt Master 9000.  third Teslas are nice but as a Visionary  you should think bigger I propose  joining the Teslas together into one  long Mega Tesla codename cyberdick  fitting hundreds of people efficiency  capacity epicness the Vegas Loop 2.0